tu es le ministre chers collègues nous
avons l'honneur d'accueillir aujourd'hui
Monsieur Olivier Duchamp ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur le ministre je
souhaite la bienvenue je vous remercie
de vous êtes rendu disponible pour
répondre à nos questions aujourd'hui
vous le savez à partir du 10 juillet
2022 plusieurs membres du consortium
international de journalisme
d'investigation on publie ce qui est
désormais convenu d'appeler les uber
files s'appuyant sur 124000 documents
internes à l'entreprise américaine d'été
de 2013 à 2017 cette enquête a dénoncé
les méthodes de lobbying de la société
uber pour implanter en France comme dans
de nombreux pays des véhicules de
transport et chauffeurs des VTC en
concurrencer le secteur traditionnel du
transport public particulier de
personnes réservées jusqu'alors au taxi
dans ce contexte notre commission
d'enquête à deux objets d'une part
identifier l'ensemble des actions de
lobbying menées par uber pour pouvoir
s'implanter en France le rôle des
décideurs publics de l'époque et mettre
des recommandations sur l'encadrement
des relations entre décideurs publics et
représentants d'intérêt d'autre part
pour ambition d'évaluer les conséquences
économiques sociales environnementales
du développement du modèle uber en
France l'ubérisation
et les réponses apportées et à apporter
par les décideurs publics en la matière
dans ce cadre nous avons beaucoup
travaillé sur les nouvelles formes de
travail du Sud du développement des
plateformes numériques à travers la mise
en avant du statut d'indépendant lequel
est parfois dévoyé car les relations
entre certaines plateformes et leur
travailleur s'apparente parfois du
salariat déguisé donnant lieu à des
requalifications par le juge comme l'ont
appelé les représentants de la Cour de
cassation que nous avons pu auditionner
plusieurs plateformes ont été par
ailleurs pénalement sanctionnés pour
travailler illégal grâce au travail de
l'inspection du travail dans les
effectifs ont été récemment renforcés
comme nous le rappeler le directeur
général du travail et son adjointe au
cours de nos auditions la question du
dialogue social c'est du renforcement du
droit des travailleurs des plateformes
également émerger comme des sujets
majeurs nous avons pu constater au
travers de nos nombreuses auditions plus
d'une centaine qu'à la suite des
propositions de Jean-Yves froid et la
tasse force medpling le gouvernement
engagé une réforme inédite à travers la
création de l'autorité des relations
sociales et des plateformes d'emploi
l'ARP les premiers accords sur les
minimum les courses VTC et des livreurs
de même que les modalités de rupture du
lien commercial entre plateforme et
livreurs et l'agenda social 2023 ont pu
ainsi être négocié et signé nous avons
également abordé la question centrale du
management algorithmique instauré par
les plateformes numériques la
compatibilité des algorithmes avec le
rgpd leur manque de transparence pour
les utilisateurs ainsi que les risques
et conséquences de la collecte massive
de données par des entreprises telles
qu'Hubert en tant que ministre du
Travail du plein emploi de l'insertion
évidemment ces sujets vous préoccupent
autant que notre commission d'enquête
c'est pourquoi il nous a semblé
indispensable de vous auditionner pour
connaître votre vision votre action
celle du gouvernement sur les
conséquences du développement des
plateformes numériques sur le travail en
France nous aurons de nombreuses
questions à vous poser ce matin à
commencer par les suivantes l'état
considère-t-il avoir les moyens de
pouvoir contrôler encadrer l'impact de
l'ubérisation sur l'organisation du
travail et les conditions de travail des
travailleurs des plateformes numériques
la création de l'autorité sociale des
relations sociales l'autorité des
relations de plateforme l'art créer le
21 avril 2021 était adaptée aux enjeux
dont nous parlons alors que son champ
d'intervention et est limité aujourd'hui
à certaines plateformes de mobilité la
négociation en cours sur le projet
directive européenne relative à
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
via les plateformes peut-être être une
opportunité pour réguler davantage les
relations de travail au sein de
l'ensemble des plateformes au bénéfice
des travailleurs tout en assurant les
conditions de l'innovation d'une
concurrence saine et enfossé et de la
création d'emploi
dans l'affirmative pouvez-vous nous
préciser quelle est la position du
gouvernement français sur les
propositions de la Commission européenne
relatives à la présomption de salariat
nous aurons bien sûr d'autres questions
à vous poser avec mes collègues mais je
vous propose d'entamer notre discussion
à ce stade je rappelle que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse qu'elle
est retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et avant de vous
laisser la parole monsieur le ministre
je vous rappelle que l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité j'ai donc vous inviter à
activer votre micro lever la main droite
et dire je le jure je le jure merci
Monsieur mi je vous laisse la parole
pardon merci monsieur le président
madame le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés quelques mots
d'abord pour vous dire que bien
évidemment je réponds bien volontiers à
la fois à votre convocation et vos
questions que vous aurez à poser
concernant les sujets que vous avez
abordés peut-être qu'avant d'apporter
des éléments de réponse au séries de
questions que vous avez au séries de
sujets que vous avez évoqué monsieur le
Président me permettrait vous de faire
une remarque préalable vous avez dit que
votre commission avait deux sujets et
que le premier des sujets était des
conditions dans lesquelles la société
uber s'était implantée en France entre
2012 et 2016 cela m'amène à porter
d'emblée quelques précisions d'abord
pour rappeler que au moment de cette
implantation et ce travail
d'implantation je n'étais pas membre du
gouvernement que pour ce qui me concerne
et dans les fonctions qui sont les
miennes aujourd'hui j'ai été nommé il y
a un an à deux jours près et à un moment
donc où uber était parfaitement implanté
si on peut se permettre cette
appréciation qualitative les
administrations de mon ministère et de
mon cabinet ont dans le cas normal de
leur travail tant sous ma responsabilité
sous celle de mes prédécesseurs
rencontrer des représentants des
plateformes dont des représentants du
beurre mais pas seulement pour ce qui me
concerne à titre personnel je n'ai
jamais eu à ce ministère ou ailleurs de
contact direct avec l'entreprise du
beurre j'aurais pu en avoir d'ailleurs
car le ministère comme ceux que j'ai
occupé précédemment
même plusieurs sujets plusieurs
chantiers qui auraient pu concerner les
plateformes et nécessité de telles
rencontres considérant que ces
rencontres sont aussi l'occasion de
mener des politiques des politiques
publiques plus fonctionnelles plus
pertinentes et non pas déconner
déconnecter des réalités économiques et
sociales je le dis parce que je
considère que avoir ou ne pas avoir
rencontré la société uber ou d'autres
sociétés de plateforme ne relève pas
d'un évaluation d'une appréciation
positive ou négative ça s'inscrit dans
un cadre normal pour ce qui me concerne
les mesures que j'ai conduites et les
réforme que j'ai conduites rue de
Grenelle depuis ma nomination n'ont pas
nécessité non pas justifié non pas
amener de rencontres de ce type là
j'ai écouté monsieur le Président les
sujets que vous avez listés j'ai pris
connaissance des travaux de votre
commission avant de me rendre devant
vous aujourd'hui et j'espère pouvoir
apporter des éléments de réponse en
articulant mon propos pour 3 points le
premier concerne l'encadrement de
l'activité des plateformes et la
position du ministère du Travail à ce
sujet le deuxième concerne le
positionnement de du système
d'inspection du travail par rapport au
travail de plateforme et aux sociétés
concernées et enfin le troisième
concerne les relations qui peuvent être
entretenues par le ministère que ce soit
au niveau des cabinets ou des services
avec les sociétés de plateformes pour ce
qui concerne le premier point et
l'encadrement de l'activité des
plateformes il y a quatre aspects qu'il
me semble devoir être souligné la loi
d'abord telle qu'elle est prévue le
dialogue social tel qu'il est organisé
la jurisprudence telle qu'on la connaît
et le droit l'Union européenne telle
qu'elle se construit pour ce qui
concerne la structuration par le cadre
normatif je dois rappeler que depuis
2016 face au développement rapide et non
régulier des plateformes les
gouvernements sont successivement
progressivement construit un socle de
droit pour les travailleurs plateformes
la loi du 8 août 2016 relative au
travail la modernisation du dialogue
social et à la sécurisation des parcours
à poser une première pierre en créant
une responsabilité sociale des
plateformes à l'égard des travailleurs
au courant leur service et
l'établissement de cette responsabilité
par du principe que ces travailleurs
bien indépendant dépendent pour partie
des conditions d'activité fixées
unilatéralement par la plateforme qui
détermine par exemple les
caractéristiques ou le prix des
prestations ainsi que le bien fourni par
le travailleur il y a donc une certaine
responsabilité des plateformes à l'égard
des travailleurs concernés et cette
responsabilité sociale s'exerce par la
prise en charge des cotisations
d'assurance volontaires quand le risque
d'accident du travail par la
contribution formation professionnelle
et par des frais d'accompagnement à la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
le travailleur peut aussi bénéficier de
ses prises en charge si il a réalisé sur
la plateforme un chiffre d'affaires au
moins égal à 13 % du plafond annuel de
sécurité sociale soit en 2023 5718 euros
la loi dit elkhomri a aussi instauré
l'équivalent d'un droit de grève pour
les travailleurs indépendants ayant
recours à une plateforme ainsi que la
liberté de constituer une organisation
syndicale et d'y adhérée ensuite notre
majorité a continué de protéger les
travailleurs avec la loi d'orientation
des mobilités du 24 décembre 2019 entre
autres mesures cette loi oblige les
plateformes à communiquer pour chaque
proposition de course la distance et le
prix minimal ce qui n'était pas le cas
auparavant et cette loi a ainsi mis fin
en situation les travailleurs
indépendants acceptaient d'offrir un
service dont ils ignoraient la nature et
la rémunération et donc à améliorer la
protection des travailleurs plateformes
cette obligation est aussi assortie
d'une série de protection dans le code
des transports dont le droit de refuser
une prestation encore une protection
contre ce que nous pourrions appeler les
représailles la l'homme améliore aussi
considérablement le droit à la formation
des travailleurs indépendants par
exemple on obligeant l'abonnement du
compte personnel de formation par la
plateforme au-delà d'un certain chiffre
d'affaires réalisés
le deuxième point qui constitue
l'encadrement normatif aujourd'hui
concerne la question d'un choix français
qui est le choix du dialogue social
puisque au-delà des jalons normatifs la
France a surtout fait le choix du
dialogue social pour améliorer le droit
des travailleurs des plateformes et
c'est une spécificité française que nous
défendons dans le cas des discussions
européennes sur lesquelles je reviendrai
c'est un choix de confiance dans la
concertation entre les représentants des
travailleurs et ceux des plateformes
c'est finalement le pari du dialogue et
du consensus
nous considérons que l'objectif de cette
concertation entre présentant et
d'élaborer des droits et d'assurer le
développement économique du secteur mais
pas de revenir sur les statuts existants
il revient en effet toujours au juge en
appréciant les situations au cas par cas
de requalifier le statut d'un travail
dans les conditions d'exercice ne sert
pas à celle d'un indépendant
en vertu de ce principe et de ce choix
en vertu de la l'homme aussi mon
application de la l'homme plus
exactement plusieurs ordonnances on sont
venus encadrer dialogue social d'abord
celle du 21 avril 2021 qui instaure le
principe d'un dialogue social entre
plateformes de la mobilité et
travailleurs qui recouvre et elle a créé
à l'article
lc7345-1 du Code du travail l'Autorité
de régulation des plateformes d'emploi
qui enchères qui est en charge de
l'organisation du dialogue social dans
le secteur l'art vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le Président est sous la
tutelle de mon ministère et celui des
transports elle permet aux acteurs de
plateformes de disposer d'un tiers de
confiance qui facilite l'instauration et
la conduite du dialogue et son
financement est assuré par une taxe
acquitée par les plateformes
l'ordonnance en question a aussi
organisée la représentation des
travailleurs des plateformes sur le
principe d'une élection nationale et à
l'occasion des élections de mai 2022
cette organisation de voiture transport
avec chauffeur et 4 organisations de
livreurs ont été reconnus comme
représentatives nous savons tous que les
taux de participation étaient faibles
pour les livreurs 3,9 du côté des VTC
pourtant ces tonnes remettent engrais en
cause la légitimité la légitimité des
représentants puisqu'il s'agissait de
première élections dans un secteur qui
n'est ni familier ni vraiment
sensibilisé à cette question de dialogue
social par exemple nous pouvons aussi
relativiser cette eau puisque la
dernière la participation dernière
élection dans les TPE s'est levée à
5,5%. j'espère bien évidemment je crois
que nous pouvons tous espérer que les
prochaines élections organisées en 2024
seront l'occasion de mieux faire
connaître le scrutin et ses enjeux
l'ordonnance prévoit aussi une série de
mesures pour les représentants des
travailleurs de plateformes ils sont
ainsi protégés d'une baisse d'activité
liée à l'exercice de leur mandat il
bénéficie d'autres formations et
délégation pour exercer leur mission qui
sont prises en charge et compenser
forfaitairement
il y a une deuxième ordonnance qu'il
faut citer celle du 6 avril 2022 qui
prévoit les modalités de représentation
des plateformes de mobilité pour les VTC
les livraisons et la représentativité
des organisations des plateformes ainsi
été précisé à l'article 73 43-22 du code
du travail et les tissus à la fois du
nombre de travailleurs et du montant
total de leurs revenus d'activité donc
sur cette base dans le secteur des VTC
sont reconnus depuis septembre 2022
l'association des plateformes
d'indépendants à 61% qui regroupe uber
et chaos chaos et sont aussi est aussi
reconnus la Fédération Française du
transport de personnes sur réservation à
hauteur 39% qui regroupe notamment les
plateformes françaises frinio freeaux
hitch Bolt Marcel le CAB et Allocab pour
ce qui concerne les livreurs seuls l'API
représentative un regroupant notamment
les plateformes uber eats delivero et
Stuart l'ordonnance fixe également les
règles du dialogue social sectoriel en
créant une commission de négociation
pour la négociation des accords
sectoriels ainsi que leurs conditions de
validité et l'article 73 49 73 43 pardon
29 du travail prévoit ainsi qu'un accord
de secteur signé par des organisations
de travailleurs représentant plus de 30%
des suffrages exprimés homologués par
l'art sera rendu obligatoire condition
que l'accord soit accepté par des
organisations qui représentent la
majorité des travailleurs de plateforme
cette ordonnance prévoit enfin les
obligations de négociation pour
favoriser la conclusion d'accord
annuelle sur au moins un des quatre
thèmes centraux du secteur la
détermination des revenus des
travailleurs les conditions d'exercice
de l'activité professionnelle notamment
en termes de temps de travail la
prévention des risques professionnels et
les dommages causés à des tiers ainsi
que les modalités de développement des
compétences professionnelles et de
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
je souhaite souligner que ce choix de
faire confiance au dialogue social à
enregistré de première réussite du côté
des VTC les organisations
représentatives des travailleurs et des
plateformes en signant un premier accord
le 18 janvier dernier fixant un revenu
minimum de 7,65 mètres par course ce qui
équivaut une hausse de 27% du tarif le
plus bas le plus bas pratiqué sur le
marché et je note aussi que c'est
d'ailleurs pour l'entreprise uber cet
accord aura le plus d'effet puisque les
autres avaient déjà aligné leur minima
auparavant ce premier accord mais
évidemment pas un terme à la discussion
sur les revenus il prévoit d'ailleurs la
tenue de négociation sectorielle début
2023 pourtant je pense que c'est une
première démonstration de la volonté des
acteurs d'atteindre un consensus et donc
de la pertinence du modèle et du choix
du dialogue social que nous avons fait
du côté des livreurs trois accords ont
été proposés le 20 avril dernier par
l'API
un premier restaurant nouveau droit plus
plus protecteur pour les livrer en amont
et en aval de la rupture du lien
commercial à l'initiative de la
plateforme un deuxième accord qui
instaure un revenu minimal garanti
horaire à hauteur de 11,75 un dernier
accord a loin des ressources
supplémentaires représentants des
travailleurs indépendants c'est aussi
une première réussite dans ce secteur
particulier du dialogue social une
première étape qui démontre une
dynamique positive dans le secteur
troisième point qui forme le cadre
normatif s'agit de l'état de la
jurisprudence c'est le troisième pilier
de cette encadrement des plateformes et
il est plus que dans notre secteur
important en donnant notamment de
l'importance aux juge prédomal de fait
la définition du lien de subordination
et la relation de salariale revient
c'est à dire qu'elle fait l'objet d'une
appréciation au cas par cas en fonction
l'analyse d'un faisceau d'indice par le
juge depuis l'arrêt de la chambre
sociale de la courte cassation dit
Société Générale du 13 novembre 96 le
lien ne subordination est défini comme
l'exécution du travail d'un travail sous
l'autorité d'un employeur qui a la main
sur l'ensemble des interactions il a le
pouvoir de donner des ordres et les
directives de contrôler l'exécution et
de sanctionner les manquements de son
subordonnés ce raisonnement s'applique
en réalité à tout travailleur qui
sollicite la reconnaissance des lionne
subordination dont les travailleurs
plateformes qui souhaitent une
requalification de leur statue en
salariés
et ces critères se retrouvent dans les
derniers arrêts récemment rendus à
l'encontre par exemple du beurre c'est
le cas dans un arrêt de la Cour de
cassation du 4 mars 2020 ou bien de
taïkitisme dans un autre arrêt du 28
novembre 2018 par exemple pour compléter
dans son arrêt du 25 janvier 2023 très
récent concernant uber la Chambre
Sociale de la grande cassation a
considéré la détermination par la
Plateforme des convictions des
conditions d'exécution du travail comme
un indice de subordination et ce
conformément à sa jurisprudence
constante à l'inverse elle a considéré
dans un arrêt du 13 avril 2022 qu'il n'y
a pas de contrat de travail entre un
travailleur et la plateforme boxsture
concluant qu'il manque d'éléments
caractérisant l'exercice au sein d'un
service qualifié d'organisé le droit
protège donc les travailleurs des
plateformes comme tous les autres
travailleurs à partir de la singularité
de la complexité de leur cas
interrogé monsieur le Président sur le
droit de l'Union européenne en
construction c'est le dernier pilier de
l'encadrement des plateformes de
mobilité qui est en construction la
proposition de directive relative à
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
dans le cas du travail via une
plateforme est en cours de discussion au
conseil c'est à dire au niveau des États
après avoir fait l'objet d'un vote au
Parlement européen en février dernier ce
projet directive il a définir une
approche par le statut sur la base de
critères qui permettrait de caractériser
une relation de subordination entre un
travailleur et une plateforme c'est pour
cela qu'on parle de présomption de
salariat tout l'enjeu pour la France et
pouvoir concilier ce cadre européen
construction avec le dispositif que nous
avons bâti dans le cadre de la loi de
2016 plus de London et des ordonnances
que j'ai citées et ainsi nos positions
en Europe découlent nécessairement de
tout ce que je vous ai exposé comme
cadre national que nous avons construit
nous regrettons que le texte présenté
par la présidente tchèque au Conseil des
ministres du travail de l'Union
européenne le 8 décembre dernier à
Bruxelles n'est pas réussi à trouver une
majorité qualifiée parmi les États
membres nous étions réel votés nous
l'avons dit lors de la réunion du
conseil nous l'avons déclaré
publiquement même s'il représentait déjà
pour nous de très grandes concessions
par rapport au modèle que nous avons
bâti nous sommes engagés sur une voie
singulière et que nous considérons comme
équilibrer ça lui dialogue social qui
permet de cadrer le développement
économique des plateformes et d'assurer
la mise en place de nouveaux droits
définis par les représentants des
travailleurs eux-mêmes tout en
protégeant le statut des véritables
travailleurs indépendants c'est cette
voie que nous défendons devant nos
partenaires européens et qui
représentent un point d'équilibre au
sein du Conseil elle passe par
l'exigence d'une définition suffisamment
précise des critères d'application de la
présomption de salariat prévu dans le
projet de directive pour préserver les
statuts existants et le modèle français
de négociation collective nous
continuerons nous restons mobilisés pour
aboutir aux meilleurs textes possible
capable à la fois d'améliorer le droit
des millions de travailleurs plateformes
en Europe et lutter contre les statues
faussement indépendantes un projet
prochain conseil des ministres européens
du travail se tient le 12 juin prochain
et il est prévu par la président
suédoise la possibilité l'ordre du jour
n'est pas encore déterminé fixé je crois
d'aborder un vote d'orientation générale
non pas un vote sur la directive mais
plutôt d'orientation générale
je ne sais pas si ce point restera ainsi
inscrit à l'ordre du jour de du Conseil
EBSCO dans la mesure où la réunion du
comité des représentants permanents qui
s'est tenu hier pour préparer le
conseiller PSO du 12 juin à montrer une
très grande
pluralité et de très grandes différences
de position entre les différents États
membres non pas entre ceux qui seraient
pour et ceux qui seraient contre ce
projet directive mais véritablement avec
une singularité des dispositions et des
positions de chacun des États qui
amènent plutôt à considérer les
expressions autour de trois ou quatre
blocs et non pas sur un affrontement ou
une opposition entre des pours et des
contres
le deuxième sujet après le cadre
normatif concerne l'intervention de
l'inspection du travail dans le contrôle
de l'application du droit aux
entreprises en général et aux
plateformes en particulier
c'est le deuxième sujet je crois qui
relève de mon portefeuille et qui
concerne les plateformes avec ce
contrôle du droit des travailleurs des
plateformes qui n'est pas sans lien avec
les débats relatifs à l'activité de ces
acteurs les plateformes pour l'objet
d'un contrôle précis dans le cadre du
plan d'action de l'inspection du travail
et du plan national de lutte contre le
travail légal dans le plan national de
lutte contre le travail des illégal pour
2020 2022 la lutte contre les faux
statué était un axe prioritaire pour les
services déconcentrés de l'inspection du
travail le plan national d'action du
système d'inspection du travail pour
2023 2025 reprend cet objectif de lutte
contre le travail illégal et le plan
national de lutte contre le travail
légal pour 2023 à 2027 que j'ai présenté
aux partenaires sociaux ce lundi 22 mai
fait de la prise en compte des fraudes
émergentes en lien avec le développement
des plateformes de mise en relation un
axe majeur du travail de l'inspection du
travail
l'inspection du travail au sein des
plateformes de mise en relation vérifie
donc la réalité du statut de travailleur
du travailleur du statut de travailleurs
indépendant
si le contrôle et les investigations qui
peuvent être assez longs à mener
conduisent à considérer qu'il y a en
réalité une relation de subordination
entre les travailleurs qui se déclarent
indépendants et la plateforme
l'inspection du travail en tire les
conséquences juridiques et engage les
suites qui lui paraissent les plus
appropriées
jusqu'à la procédure pénale notamment
pour dissimulation d'emplois salarié sur
ce dernier point l'article 17 va
conversion internationale numéro 80 de
l'Organisation internationale du travail
précise qu'il est laissé la libre
décision des inspecteurs du travail de
donner des avertissements ou des
conseils au lieu d'inventer ou de
recommander les poursuites il
n'appartient donc à aucune autorité
publique même juridictionnelle il y a un
quelconque tiers de tenter d'influencer
les suites susceptibles d'être donnés au
constat aux opérés le champ de
compétence ci-dessus indiqué relatif à
la lutte contre les fossatures peut
induire le cas échéant s'il fait sous
l'indice est suffisant un procès-verbal
pour prélicite de main d'oeuvre et
travail dissimulé sans impact immédiat
sur la situation individuelle des
travailleurs et en fait l'objet d'un
contrôle je rappelle si besoin n'était
que la requalification de la relation du
travail de la relation de travail relève
du juge du contrat soit le conseil des
prud'hommes et non pas l'inspection du
travail en tant que tel
si le contrôle conduit à considérer que
le travailleur relève bien du statut de
travailleur indépendant alors en
disposition en dehors pardon des
dispositions spécifiques applicables aux
travailleurs indépendants l'inspection
du travail n'a pas de compétences
matérielles pour intervenir à
l'exception de celle prévue aux deux
articles suivants du Code du travail
l'article L45 35-1 relatif au sujet de
la coordination des interventions sur
les chantiers de BTP en matière de santé
et sécurité au travail et l'article
l7341-1
et c'est suivant qui concerne les droits
des travailleurs utilisant une
plateforme de mise en relation par voie
électronique dont j'ai rappelé le
contenu il y a quelques minutes
l'intervention de l'inspection est donc
centrée sur le contrôle de la réalité du
statut invoqué par le travailleur et la
plateforme
pour ce qui concerne les contrôles
plusieurs contrôles d'envergure ont eu
lieu directement pour des plateformes
ainsi depuis 2016 18 plateformes ont
fait l'objet d'action de contrôle
approfondir en matière de travail légale
en particulier sur la problématique des
faux statues et dont 8 des selles sont
des plateformes de mobilité depuis 2016
toujours la société uber a fait l'objet
de trois enquêtes deux pour uber eats et
une pour la société uber VTC en
complément les agents de l'inspection du
travail étant les agents de constat ils
sont amenés également contre les
directement les chauffeurs VTC lors de
leurs interventions de livraison
ces contrôles sont enregistrés au type
de l'identité du travailleur indépendant
sans pour autant qu'il ne soit possible
de le rattacher directement une
plateforme ainsi en 2021 une action a
été déployée dans plusieurs régions
visant notamment identifier des
situations de sous-location de compte
son 26 contrôles qui ont été menées
concernant 426 travailleurs soit un
échantillon représentatif des
plateformes de rattachement
ubereats
avaient permis d'objectiver par un
échantillon un échantillonnage de la
pratique de la sous-location de compte à
hauteur de 14,79% sur le territoire
national
des procédures pénales ont été établies
à l'encontre des Tuilières de comptes
qui se comportent en tant qu'employeur
ne déclarant pas leurs salariés en
particulier pour le travail dissimulé du
fait de l'emploi illégal de livreur en
sous-location je ne peux enfin que
rappeler le principe clair et sans
nuances d'indépendance de l'inspection
du travail dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions peut-être uber comme les
autres plateformes comme toutes les
autres entreprises en France d'ailleurs
ne peut faire l'objet du moins de
traitement différencié l'inspection du
travail détermine les contrôles monnaie
notamment dans le cas des orientations
nationales données par la direction
générale du travail mais Monsieur le
Directeur Général a dû exposer ses
points elle n'est donc pas mobilisable à
loisir et elle dispose de toute
opportunité quand au sud donné c'est
indépendance est une garantie
essentielle à laquelle je suis sûr
qu'elles semblent l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale est attachée je
termine monsieur le Président par les
relations des représentants de
plateformes avec le ministère
ce sont ces relations qui donnent corps
à la concertation et qui permet brique
par briques de construire le cadre
juridique du secteur toutes les grandes
plateformes ont été régulièrement
consultées non uber sans qu'aucune
relation privilégiée ou exclusive n'a
été entretenue avec cette entreprise en
particulier
ces relations n'ont rien d'exceptionnel
l'essentiel des échanges ont eu lieu au
niveau des cabinets des administrations
comme les usages dans ce cas en fin de
compte plus fréquent que vous ne laissez
entendre parfois dans tel ou telle
observations plus précisément des
concertations formelles ont été
organisées lors de la rédaction des
ordonnances et comme je vous l'ai dit je
n'ai jamais rencontré personnellement de
représentants du beurre même si je ne
considère pas cela comme en bien ou en
mal cela tient au fait que les réformes
que je mène n'ont pas nécessité ce type
de rencontre jusqu'à présent en revanche
les administrations du ministère comme
on cabinet ont reçu à plusieurs reprises
des représentants des plateformes dont
uber sur diverses réformes en cours dans
les ordonnances que j'ai évoquées tout à
l'heure les principales plateformes de
livraison de repas par exemple étaient
convoqués à plusieurs reprises au
ministère au sujet de la lutte contre la
fraude l'objectif étant lutter contre
les pratiques de travail dissimulé de
sous-traitants sans cascade dans l'un
des effets l'absence totale de
protection sociale des travailleurs et
ces réunions abouti à la signature d'une
charte de lutte contre la fraude en mars
2022 avant que je prenne mes fonctions
j'aimerais en dernier lieu redire
combien il est normal pour moi et même
nécessaire d'entretenir un contact avec
ses acteurs directement associés au
public aux politiques publiques réforme
engager mais aussi pour bien mesurer les
effets qu'ils ont sur l'organisation du
marché du travail
se passer de ce contact avec les
entreprises mais en réalité ni possible
ni souhaitable et donc j'appelle de mes
vœux toute forme de prénom sur la
manière dont parfois est jeter un doute
sur la nature des relations de la
société civile et décideur voilà
monsieur le Président ce que je pouvais
dire en réponse à vos premières
interventions autour des trois sujets
qui me semblent du périmètre de mon
ministère
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
réponses précises j'aurais juste deux
questions avant de me tourner vers
l'important à la première vous vous avez
mentionné le fait que ce n'est pas à
l'inspection du travail mais au juge du
contrat de procéder à des
requalifications est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer dans quelle mesure les
différentes décisions de requalification
qui sont prises par le juge cours de
cassation prud'hommes doivent engager ou
non le l'acteur public a procédé à des
requalifications massives en salariat
des travailleurs des plateformes
ma deuxième question sur le point que
vous venez de mentionner si vous pouvez
juste entrer un tout petit peu plus dans
le dans le détail sur la question des
des livreurs des plateformes de
livraison de repas la charte qui a été
signé avant votre arrivée au ministère
si vous pouvez nous en expliquer
peut-être un peu le périmètre et si il
vous paraîtrait opportun ou non dans le
cadre du dialogue social ou d'autres
leviers d'aller plus loin pour les
plateformes de livraison sur la question
les protection sociale des des
travailleurs et la lutte ou le contrôle
en interne
face à la fraude c'est un sujet qui est
revenu notamment dans les auditions de
plateforme de livraison au cours des
dernières semaines
se présente quelques mots d'abord pour
dire que sur la question des
requalifications prononcées par la
justice et que ce soit par le juge
plutôt de mal ou par d'autres par
d'autres instances nous considérons que
ça n'est pas un acteur public de
requalifier le choix que nous avons fait
qui nous amène parfois de manière
parfois rapide à parler de présomption
d'indépendance pour ce qui vous concerne
et est un choix qui consiste à
considérer que les travailleurs qui
s'inscrivent sur les plateformes quand
cette inscription se fait de bonne foi
si on peut dire sont des indépendants
qui souhaitent travailler en s'appuyant
sur une plateforme mais qu'il y a une
possibilité pour le juge de requalifier
soit parce qu'à la suite d'un contrôle
un lien de subordination a été considéré
comme avéré et donc il appartient à
l'inspection de saisir les juridictions
et les juridictions font ensuite leur
travail en indépendance ça parce qu'un
travailleur de plateforme considère
qu'il y a un tel lien de subordination
qu'il demande lui-même la
requalification du contrat
mais dès lors qu'on est dans ce système
là qui s'appuie sur des requalifications
par votre justice
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas l'acteur
public l'État ou un autre de procéder
lui-même à ces requalifications sur la
charte qui a été signé en mai 2022 elle
a plusieurs objectifs notamment la lutte
contre la sous-traitance irrégulière
mais que notamment la lutte contre les
sous-traitance de compte qui à la fin
amène des
travailleurs à être à peine rémunérés et
absolument pas protégé s'agit de
contrôler l'authenticité de mieux
contrôler l'authenticité des documents
notamment la validité des titres de
transport il s'agit de faire en sorte
que l'ensemble des plateformes de
livraison qui s'engagent dans ces
actions garantissent aussi un suivi de
ses actions
je considère que nous pouvons toujours
aller plus loin et toujours à plus loin
aller plus loin ça passe par les
priorités et les mesures annoncées lundi
dans le cas du plan national de lutte
contre le travail illégal et évidemment
mais mes services tiendront
l'intégralité du plan à la disposition
de votre commission à la fois en
mobilisant l'URSSAF en mobilisant les
différents comités je pense notamment au
Codaf qui permet une action coordonnée
des services de l'État et en mobilisant
l'ensemble de ceux qui peuvent mener des
contrôles et garantir la régularité du
secteur aller plus loin ça passe aussi
par le dialogue social et passer par le
dialogue social c'est faire confiance à
cette représentation des livreurs et des
plateformes de livraison pour que dans
le cadre des accords qui ont été les
trois accords qui ont été proposés par
la pie et qui sont encore en cours de
signature que ces accords puissent à
nouveau renforcer la Charte sociale
entre les acteurs
si je devais peut-être résumer cette
position
je dirais que l'État soit l'initiative
en ayant suscité le dialogue d'une
première charte sociale est une bonne
chose et c'est utile mais maintenant que
le dialogue social est installé ça nous
semble plus logique que ce soit les
acteurs qui sont dans le parent charger
à l'état de veiller à la bonne
application et charge à nous
d'encourager la conclusion de telles
chartes et de tels accords mais nous
faisons confiance au dialogue social il
a montré en quelques mois qui pouvait
déjà porter ses fruits
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
ministre Olivier du soft j'ai une
première série de questions pour revenir
un peu sur vos sur vos propos vous
justifiez la mise en place d'une
responsabilité sociale des plateformes
vis-à-vis des travailleurs par le fait
que les plateformes exercent de fait une
subordination sous les travailleurs
notamment pour reprendre les éléments
que vous avez listés le contrôle et
choix des tarifs mais alors pourquoi à
partir du moment où on permet à des
plateformes d'utilisation du statut de
travailleurs indépendant alors même
quels exercent une certaine
subordination on ne l'autoriserait pas
plus largement
au-delà en fait du secteur du transport
et de la livraison et finalement quel
intérêt aurait les autres employeurs à
continuer de travailler avec des
travailleurs sous contrat de travail
finalement ce contraste salarié donc de
payer des cotisations sociales de
contribuer au financement de notre
système de retraite et d'être obligé de
respecter la le code du travail si
finalement il pourrait avoir la
possibilité de continuer à subordonner
des travailleurs tout en échappant à
l'ensemble des obligations du Code du
travail voilà donc autrement dit est-ce
que vous voyez pas que dans votre
dispositif législatif finalement en
réalité il est fait pour pouvoir être un
cheval de Troie pour des tricoter le
tout le salariat et le code du travail
qui je le rappelle a été conquis de
haute Lutz en 1910 après nombre de
nombres de grèves donc vous dites
également que tout l'enjeu c'est de
concilier le cadre européen et puis
l'évolution du travail législatif
particulier original de la France et
vous insistez beaucoup sur le dialogue
social dans le cadre de nos auditions de
la commission d'enquête parlementaire
dont je suis la rapporteur nous avons
bien compris que la stratégie et nous
les écoutrons à nouveau cet après-midi
de Hubert et des plateformes de
lubérisation du capitalisme de
plateforme et finalement ils sont bien
compte que de décision de justice en
décision de justice ils perdent et le
lien de subordination est une évidence
et donc les travailleurs sont sommets
d'être qualifiés en salariés plutôt les
plateformes sont sommet de requalifiant
salarié leur travailleur bien donc
quelle est la stratégie du verre et des
plateformes c'est de dire ah ben alors à
ce moment-là on va essayer de trouver un
peu un tiers statut entre le statut
d'indépendant et le statut de salarié
part de nouveaux droits sociaux et
finalement nous défendons l'idée d'un
dialogue social je reprends en fait dans
une tribune des dirigeants d'Hubert
suite à la publication de leur better
deal il cite d'ailleurs la France en
exemple en fait au niveau de cette
stratégie certains pays européens
montrent déjà la voie voilà ce que dit
disent les dirigeants du maire dans une
tribune sponsorisée la France a acheté
une série de réformes progressives
augmentant le niveau de transparence et
de choix que les plateformes devraient
offrir au travailleurs tout en
garantissant des protections telles que
l'assurance obligatoire et la formation
professionnelle exactement quelque chose
que vous nous avez développé et on est
dans un moment particulier lorsque
Hubert écrit cela c'est avant la
création de l'ARPE mais ils savent déjà
que la France est dans ce dans cette
dans ce cheminement là de dialogue
social et finalement pour eux ce
dialogue social permet certes de
nouveaux droits pour les travailleurs
mais surtout leur empêcher toute les
protéger pour empêcher toute
qualification salarié et j'en arrive
aussi à l'autre aspect de ma question en
ce moment alors que la Commission
européenne s'est prononcé enfin en
faveur d'une directive présomption de
salariat que le Parlement européen est
également en faveur d'une directive de
présomption de salariat réfragable vous
avez lors de l'audition sur l'avant
projet France travail assumez que vous
vous étiez en faveur de la présomption
d'indépendance or nous avons auditionné
le SGAE générale aux Affaires
européennes pour dire mais c'est quand
même assez étonnant on n'a toujours pas
de publication
et de débat à l'Assemblée nationale sur
la position qui va être défendue par la
France au Conseil de l'Union européenne
sur cette directive présomption de
salariat et on a très bien compris qu'en
fait la France elle cherche à torpiller
cette directive présomption de salariat
en ajoutant des critères en disant par
exemple que si le critère du tarif on
fait partie si un pays qui a mis en
place si un pays a mis en place un tarif
minimum il faudra pas que les salariés
pour ne pas s'appuyer sur ce critère là
et surtout vous souhaitez que les pays
qui ont notamment un dialogue social
puisse déroger à l'application cette
directive présomption de salariat autant
vous dire que pour Monsieur Schmitt que
nous avons auditionné le Commissaire
européen en charge du dossier cette
présomption d'indépendance est une
véritable ligne rouge pour la Commission
européenne or
vous êtes
souvent vous entend vous faire les
grands défenseurs de l'Europe or quand
pour une fois il y a une véritable
avancée sociale est-ce que la France
serait dans une stratégie finalement de
frexit vis-à-vis de cette directive
présomption de salariat dernière chose
vous défendez le dialogue social est-ce
que cette directive présomption de
salariat a fait l'objet d'une discussion
au sein de l'ARPE est-ce que les
confédérations syndicales ont été
entendus sur leur position sur cette
question là en tant que rapporteur je
l'aurais adressé un courrier les
confédérations syndicales m'ont bien
répondu un elle n'avait pas été
auditionnée deux elles sont favorables à
la demande que nous formulons et qui est
soutenu par Russie tous les groupes
parlementaires de la nupesse qu'il y ait
un débat à l'Assemblée nationale au nom
de l'article 50 alinéa 1 de la
Constitution assorti d'un vote sur la
position de la France qu'est-ce qu'elle
va défendre le 13 et 14 juin
ou ultérieurement concernant cette
directive présomption de salariat donc
vous l'aurez compris la question du
dialogue social semble être la bonne
stratégie pour Hubert d'empêcher toute
qualification salarié et ce qui apparaît
assez
évident c'est visiblement vous défendez
vous-même et l'ensemble du gouvernement
cette même stratégie qu'avez-vous à
répondre à cela je vous remercie
merci madame le rapporteur je vais
répondre qu'il me semble que dans votre
peau il y a deux confusions d'abord dans
la mesure où une présomption
d'indépendance comme une présomption de
salariat
ne peut toujours être renversé il n'y a
pas de présomption irréfa avec
irréfragable et c'est le propre de notre
droit français que de renvoyer la
requalification aux autorités
juridictionnelles et donc que l'on parle
de prison salariale ou de présomption
d'indépendance en France ça n'a
finalement qu'une portée juridique assez
limitée c'est ce qui m'a amené tout à
l'heure à précis dans mon propos
liminaire que je pouvais porter ce
propos parfois rapidement pour dire que
nous avons fait le choix de ne pas aller
vers une présomption de salariat qui
serait automatique
je précise par ailleurs que pour ce qui
concerne l'exercice et les conditions
d'exercice la détermination du lien de
subordination s'appuie sur un faisceau
d'indice qui comporte les moyens la
capacité à déterminer ses horaires de
travail un service organisé sans pouvoir
y échapper et qu'il y a c'est pour ça
que je parlais de confusion dans le
propos qui est le vote à l'instant en
terme de consul fusion sur les
conditions d'exercice de l'activité en
rappelant qu'un travailleur et salarié
si l'employeur peut le sanctionner un
pouvoir direction et donne des ordres et
c'est là-dessus que le juge l'apprécie
sa décision la deuxième confusion que
j'ai noté dans votre propos concerne les
positions exprimées par les différentes
parties prenantes de la discussion de la
discussion européenne le Parlement
européen dans son vote ne défend pas la
directive de la Commission
il défend une prison sans salariale
automatique et sans critères alors que
la version initiale de la du projet
directif porté par le commissaire
Schmitt est une
version une proposition qui porte des
critères assez précis que le débat parmi
les différents États membres doit
permettre de préciser enfin deux points
le premier pour rappeler qu'il n'y a pas
de tiers statut dans notre droit et que
la loi el khomri 2016 comme la Lomme et
les ordonnances qui ont suivi n'ont pas
prévu de la création d'un tiers statut
c'est un débat qui pour moi est derrière
nous qui vise notre débat de l'époque
visait à mieux protéger les travailleurs
de plateformes tout en permettant
l'activité indépendante quand elle est
indépendante et en facilitant la
requalification pour les situations de
faux statues et puis la deuxième chose
concerne la position de la France sur la
scène européenne
je ne sais pas comment vous pouvez dire
que la France voulait torpiller une
directive alors que nous avons dit
publiquement lors du Conseil expos de 8
décembre que nous étions prêt à voter la
proposition faite par la présidence
tchèque et cette position est publique
puisque elle a donné lieu à un
communiqué de presse publié sur le site
du ministère et sur le site de
gouvernementaux notamment du ministère
des Affaires étrangères et européennes
et nous avons dit lors du Conseil du 8
décembre que nous étions prêt à voter
cette directive nous l'avons exprimé il
n'y a pas une majorité pour la beauté de
la même manière qu'hier à l'occasion de
la réunion du corps et père que j'ai
évoqué il n'y a pas de majorité quand on
regarde ceux qui sont pour la version
initiale de la Commission et ceux qui
s'étaient opposés ces deux groupes se
divisent encore en leur sang et chacun
des groupes a dit les difficultés qu'il
avait avec la directive bon je pense à
ce stade le projet de directive tel
qu'il a été présenté hier me paraît
difficilement adaptable je reste prudent
chaque État est libre de ses bottes mais
il me paraît difficilement adoptable je
forme le vœu mais ce n'est pas nous qui
sommes à l'initiative c'est la
commission
que sur la base du texte qui a été
évoqué et examiné lors du Conseil
européen du 12 du 8 décembre nous
puissions reprendre les travaux et nous
avions dit le 8 décembre que malgré les
très fortes concessions que cela
impliquer nous étions prêts à voter pour
nous c'est une base de travail qui reste
d'actualité
oui monsieur le ministre vous dites
finalement qu'on parle de présomption de
salariés au présent de si on
indépendance il n'y a une différence de
portée juridique que très limitée non
c'est l'inverse c'est radicalement deux
stratégies totalement différentes la
présomption de salariat signifie quoi
d'abord la position du Parlement
européen c'est pour une prise option
réfragable salariat ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que tous les travailleurs du
des plateformes sont considérés comme
devront être qualifiés en salariés parce
que l'ensemble des décisions de justice
attestent bien qu'ils sont dans un
rapport de subordination vous avez
rappelé les décisions de la Cour de
cassation celle qui ne sont pas en
faveur de la requalification salarié
c'était fautz de comment dire de
travailleurs auditionnés dans le dossier
mais pas sur une position de fond bien
donc une présomption de salariat ferait
que l'ensemble des salariés se
requalifie requalifier en salarié
sauf si la plateforme
amenait la démonstration qu'ils sont
dans un rapport d'indépendance donc
c'est radicalement différent que votre
position qui est de plaider pour la
présomption d'indépendance ou pour
l'augmentation de critères à un nombre
tel qu'on revient à la situation
actuelle ou c'est chaque travailleur qui
doit faire la démarche au prix d'homme
donc c'est bien différemment vous n'avez
toujours pas répondu à ma question
que pensez-vous de cette exigence
démocratique au nom de l'article 50
alinéa 1 qu'il y a un débat assorti d'un
vote à l'Assemblée nationale sur la
position de la France sur cette
directive présomption de salariat ou
bien l'absence de vote va-t-il devoir
être considéré par l'ensemble des
travailleurs des travailleurs de ce pays
finalement comme un pire qu'un énième
49.3 puisque il y aurait même pas de
débats non seulement pas de vote mais
même pas de débat deuxième question vous
avez beaucoup
à juste titre présenté les
responsabilités qui sont les vôtres en
tant que ministre du Travail concernant
le travail de notamment de l'inspection
du travail j'ai plusieurs questions à ce
sujet
nous avons lors de l'audition de la
direction générale du travail bien
compris que c'était extrêmement
chronophage pour les inspecteurs de
l'Urssaf pour comme pour les inspecteurs
du travail de mener les actions de
contrôle
monsieur le Président rappelait dans son
intervention préliminaire qui avait une
augmentation des effectifs dernièrement
or les syndicats nous font état sur ces
10 dernières années d'une baisse de 20%
des effectifs de l'inspection du travail
alors même qu'il faudrait bien plus de
monde vous vous venez de nous dire qu'un
plan national de lutte contre le travail
illégal avait été mis en place 2023 2025
2033 2027 or ce que nous comprenons
c'est que à partir de ce dernier
présenté lundi que la question des
plateformes est véritablement ciblée car
dans le pnlti antérieur la question du
travail enfin de la situation sont
particulières des plateformes n’êtes pas
été abordées ça veut dire qu'il n'y a eu
aucune impulsion des gouvernements
précédents sur ces 10 dernières années
aucune impulsion pour cibler
véritablement le l'impact des
plateformes dans le mépris le
piétinement du code du travail et aucun
du coup moyen afférent c'est à dire
formation méthodologies pour accompagner
les inspections du travail et les
inspecteurs de leur URSSAF à exercer
leur travail et d'ailleurs les décisions
de les contrôles qui ont pu être opérés
à chaque fois se sont fait à
l'initiative d'inspecteur du travail et
non pas sous l'impulsion nationale
qu'avez-vous à répondre à cela et je
voudrais aussi attirer votre attention
nous avons dans le cadre notre rôle de
commission d'enquête parlementaire
sollicité le BPI France pour savoir les
moyens qui avaient été alloués alors
souvent en près d'amorçage parfois en
subvention donc de l'argent public à des
plateformes bien et nous réalisons que
des plateformes par exemple comme Mehdi
flash ont pu recevoir presque un demi
million d'euros de prêts d'amorçage
investissement en 450 millions d'euros
qui ne sont pas remboursés nous avons
par exemple brigade qui a touché plus de
presque presque 4 millions d'euros des
sommes quand même colossales or ces
plateformes là il y en a d'autres il y a
frischty il y a staffie Nao or pour
reprendre brigade et medi-flash on se
retrouve avec des plateformes qui
pendant le covid ont mis en avant la
mise en relation entre des travailleurs
un des statut indépendants comme des
aides-soignants et des établissements
publics médico-sociaux comme des EHPAD
or vous madame borne lorsqu'elle était
ministre du Travail avant vous et le
ministre de la Santé de l'époque Olivier
Véran avait été très clair dans un
courrier pour expliquer qu'en fait il
n'était pas possible et pas légal en
fait qui est des aides-soignants en
statut d'auto-entrepreneur par exemple
dans un EHPAD parce qu'il devait être
dans un rapport salarial car sous la
responsabilité de notamment des
infirmiers infirmières qu'avez-vous à
répondre à cela comment se fait-il que
dans un même gouvernement on est une
main qui donne par près d'amosage des
sommes conséquences à des plateformes
qui vont faire en fait une mise en
relation illégale et considérée comme
illégal par deux ministres
déterminants dans vis-à-vis vis-à-vis du
droit du travail
trois points pour être aussi exhaustif
que possible d'abord sur la question
présomption d'indépendance présomption
de salariat je vous laisse pardonnez-moi
le dire comme ça mais à votre
appréciation des deux modèles j'ai dit
comment la loi organiser les choses quel
était la position de la France par
rapport à la directive européenne et le
fait que nous faisons confiance à la
fois dialogue social pour la création de
droit mais aussi au juge pour la
requalification des statuts et
l'ensemble des positions que j'ai
défendues devant vous dans mon propos
éliminaire comme dans la première
réponse relève finalement de la stricte
application des votes intervenues au
Parlement et des décisions qui ont été
prises à la fois sur la question des
plateformes particulièrement et sur la
question du droit du travail en général
deuxième chose sur l'article 50-1 je
considère à titre personnel que le
Parlement a déjà beaucoup débattu de la
question des plateformes c'est la loi de
2016 ça peut ne pas vous plaire madame
la rapporteur mais je compte sur vous
pour pouvoir tordre mes propos dans une
capsule vidéo comme vous l'avez fait
avec les propos du directeur général du
travail
vous venez de dire Madame la rapporteur
que vous allez tendre mes propos je
pense que c'est intéressant pour le
compte rendu et je pense que le
Parlement a déjà beaucoup débattu je ne
reviens pas sur les différentes étapes
je dis simplement que si il devait y
avoir un débat au titre de l'article
50-1 avec un vote cela relève d'une
décision du gouvernement dans sa
collégité sous l'autorité du Premier
ministre et qui ne revient pas un
ministre dans l'exercice de ces
fonctions particulières de prendre une
telle décision sur la question de
l'inspection du travail et avant
pardonnez-moi sur les questions des
soutiens apportés par bébé France c'est
un champ qui n'est pas dans ma
responsabilité mais je ne trouve pas
anormal ni absurde qu'il y ait un
certain nombre de startups et de
sociétés qui soient aidée et boosté par
Don prendre les 6 par BPI France dans le
cadre de ses compétences mais ne revient
pas de porter un jugement ou une
évaluation dans la mesure ça ne relève
pas de mes responsabilités je peux vous
dire par contre que sur une plateforme
que vous avez évoqué et qui a pu donner
lieu à des débats et même à des
appréciations qui peuvent a priori
sembler divergente un certain nombre de
contrôles sont en cours des contrôles
menés à la fois par l'URSSAF par
l'inspection du travail pour voir
comment doit être qualifié les relations
tant avec des travailleurs du secteur
médico-social que dans la mise à
disposition ces travailleurs auprès
d'établissement de santé avec en tête le
fait que les conditions de travail
notamment le choix des horaires de
travail sont peut-être plus difficiles à
laisser à la seule appréciation des
travailleurs concernés dans les mesures
c'est une organisation très collective
et qui sont arrêtées enfin sur
l'inspection du travail
la question que vous m'avez posé le 1er
mars qui portait sur un cas particulier
et donc permettez-moi de revenir sur ce
cas particulier pour répondre à votre
question ce cas particulier concerné le
fait que l'inspection du travail était
saisi de la situation de travailleur
recouvrant pour l'exercice de leur
activité professionnelle à une
plateforme de mobilité et l'inspecteur
du travail a regardé les éléments
apportés décliner sa compétence et
donner suite à la demande dont elle
était saisie en informant le plaignant
de l'état de l'état du droit applicable
et en invitant à se rapprocher le cas
échéant du conseil des prud'hommes en
l'espèce le plénon sollicité une
intervention de l'inspection pour
obtenir des masques de protection contre
le covid l'inspection du travail au sein
des plateformes de mise en relation je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure vérifie la
réalité du statut du travail indépendant
et si elle considère que ce statut n'est
pas statut d'indépendance elle donne
toutes les conséquences juridiques et
langage des suites qui lui paraissent
les plus appropriés sachant que ces
suites sont décidés par l'inspection en
indépendance et en application des seuls
principes directeurs fixés par les
priorités élaborées et énoncées par le
directeur général du travail
le pignon en tout cas le requeront à
considéré que cette décision qui
consistait à décliner la compétence de
l'inspection du travail devait être
contestée le tribunal administratif de
Paris a partiellement fait droit à la
demande et les services de la direction
générale du travail font appel en
considérant que notre inspectrice n'a
pas commis d'erreur manifeste
d'appréciation et en procédant de la
manière dont elle l'a fait et en
rappelant qu'après la protection des
prérogatives de l'inspection du travail
est essentielle et son exercice puisque
si nous laissions cette décision sans
appel et si cette juste expérience
venait à prospérer cela signifierait
qu'un tribunal
qu'une autorité juridictionnelle
pourrait décider de diligenter ou
d'ordonner que ce soit des disjoncter
des contrôles de l'inspection du travail
c'est contraire à la Convention
internationale de l'OIT c'est la raison
pour laquelle à la fois parce que nous
considérons que notre inspectrice a
réalisé son travail et que sa décision
n'est pas susceptible de recours que
nous la défendons et la seconde raison
parce que nous défendons le cadre
international et donc l'in dépendance du
fonctionnement de l'inspection du
travail comme c'est ainsi prévu
dans le cadre du plan national de lutte
contre le travail illégal de 2020 de
2022 a été mise en été mis en place des
formations annuelles au sein de
l'Institut national de formation des
inspecteurs du travail sur ces questions
relatives aux plateformes donc vous ne
pouvez pas dire qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'initiative qui n'a pas eu
d'accompagnement l'inspection du travail
rencontre il est vrai dans sa tombe de
difficultés tout le monde les connaît
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer à ce
sujet leur examen de la mission
budgétaire concernant le ministère du
Travail
nous avons un nombre d'agents de
contrôle qui est passé de 1952 TP à 1674
et nous connaissons un taux de vacances
de 15 à 16%. nous avons lancé des
recrutements plus importants j'ai
renouvelé un certain nombre de décisions
prises par ma prédécesseur dans ses
fonctions de ministre du Travail à la
fois pour autoriser des recrutements par
détachement pour autoriser le
recrutement contractuel évidemment sur
des missions qui nous relèvent pas du
statut et des missions que je
qualifierais de régalienne pardon si le
mot est un propre mais en tout cas
réservé au corps strictement au corps
strict de l'inspection du travail et
nous avons un nombre de recrutement
prévu dans le cadre du PDF 2023 qui
s'élève à 300 pour l'année 2023 ça n'a
jamais été atteint jusqu'à présent et
nous avons par ailleurs c'est une
information qui est positive un nombre
d'inscris au concours et de recevoir le
concours qui tend à augmenter ce qui
nous donne bon espoir d'atteindre cette
cible de 300 en tout et pour tout
les recrutements lancés en 2021 et 2022
vont permettre de voir la rue dans les
services de 441 agents d'ici début 2024
et les recrutements que nous avons
ouvert cette année avec 300 recrutements
nous permettront de compléter de faire
face au départ et une pyramide des âges
qui est ce qu'elle est mais aussi c'est
l'objectif que nous poursuivions de
retrouver un taux d'occupation de
l'ensemble des postes ouverts au sein du
système d'inspection du travail qui
permet d'effacer cette situation de
vacances cela passe par d'autres mesures
évidemment sur lesquelles je ne reviens
pas je ne suis pas je ne crois pas que
ce soit l'essentiel de votre commission
notamment des mesures d'attractivité
j'ai ainsi procédé à une première
revalorisation
indemnitaire du cadre du corps des
inspecteurs du travail en privilégiant
notamment les responsables d'unités de
contrôle et dans le cadre du PDF pour
2024 je défends aussi de nouvelles
mesures qu'on qualifie parfois de
catégoriales pour améliorer les
conditions d'exercice des inspecteurs
très rapidement monsieur le ministre je
ne vous décevrai pas je continuerai à
faire des vidéos et non je ne tords pas
la réalité mais cette question est
centrale cette question du Code du
travail de la défense du salariat
trois petites choses premièrement les
députés européens Renaissance
ont voté pour la directive la
proposition directive européenne de
présomption réfragale de salariat qui
contrairement à ce que vous dites rien
d'automatique c'est une présomption
réfragable de salariat deuxièmement vous
savez pertinemment que si c'est au
salarié seulement enfin aux travailleurs
pardon des plateformes de faire les
démarches pour démontrer leur
subordination c'est extrêmement
long écoute pour des travailleurs
précaires et Monsieur le Ministre
transmettait à la commission d'enquête
parlementaire le pnlti qui montre
que les plateformes sont ciblées car
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
connaissance et dans les pnlti
antérieurs sur les 10 dernières années
les plateformes n'étaient jamais ciblées
je vous remercie
vous aurez le document je l'ai dit je ne
partage pas votre appréciation sur le
caractère automatique du projet
directive européen européenne et quand
opposition exprimée par les députés du
groupe Rogneux ça s'appelle la
séparation des pouvoirs
merci j'ai plusieurs questions je
commence avec Monsieur seguinski
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre remercier pour les aimants que
vous avez présenté moi je souhaiterais
poser une question un peu plus
prospective concernant le régime de
micro-entreprise
parce qu'on peut constater que
c'est un régime qui peut
amener une certaine précarité et aussi
d'un point de vue économique par moment
une concurrence et de loyers notamment
dans le dans ce qui concerne l'artisanat
et donc y a-t-il des réflexions en cours
pour améliorer ce régime et par ailleurs
faudrait-il promouvoir ou mieux faire
connaître des modèles alternatifs comme
par exemple le statut d'entrepreneur
salariés ou le portage salarial je vous
remercie
c'est un sujet qui relève monsieur le
député plutôt de la compétence du
ministère de l'Économie des Finances
c'est évidemment un sujet de débat
notamment l'initiative des partenaires
sociaux organisation syndicales
organisation patronales je pense
notamment à l'u2p ça ne surprendra
personne quand on connaît les positions
qui sont portées pour ce qui concerne le
statut d'automneur ou d'entrepreneurs
salariés et le portage salarial ce sont
des statuts qui sont évidemment
intéressants sur lesquels les services
du ministère travaillent notamment dans
le cadre
particulièrement puisque notamment dans
le cadre des emplois qualifiés donc ça
fait partie des de nos sujets bien
évidemment y compris dans le tailleur
dans dans le cadre de lutte contre la
fraude et de travail
les micro-entreprises de travail illégal
ou dissimulé
si j'ai madame rouleau
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez tout à l'heure
vous-même et vous qu'est la fraude
existence sur cette plateforme et votre
volonté ou la nécessité avec le dialogue
social d'améliorer la loi existante qui
les gouverne alors j'ai deux questions
très simples aujourd'hui êtes-vous en
mesure de nous dire combien il
existerait parce qu'on nous en a parlé à
une précédente audition de faux comptes
sur les plateformes certains faisant de
travailler des personnes en situation
irrégulière
ça c'est ma première question donc sur
le nombre de pourcentages un pourcentage
mais aussi et la deuxième question c'est
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
les mesures qui seront prises justement
pour lutter contre cette fraude sur les
plateformes que vous avez vous-même
reconnues merci monsieur le ministre
merci madame la députée sur la question
du nombre de faux comptes si nous
connaissions le nombre exact nous les
démonterions et nous les déconnecterons
je pense qu'il y en a plusieurs milliers
mais un audit est en cours et c'est
justement un audit mené par chacune des
plateformes dans le cadre de la charte
sociale donc nous avons accompagné en
mars 2022 le ministère accompagné la
mise en œuvre et donc ces audits nous
permettront d'y voir un peu plus clair
j'ai vu j'ai dit tout à l'heure que dans
le cadre
d'une opération spécifique menée en 2021
il avait été estimé que jusqu'à 14% de
certains comptes de livraison pouvait
faire l'objet non pas d'un faux compte
mais d'une sous-location ce qui est un
peu différent et ce qui renvoie ce qui
peut renvoyer aussi à du travail
dissimulé au des formes de
requalification nous avons un sujet
d'amélioration à mettre en oeuvre qui
est une amélioration essentiellement
logistique et technique mais les
services de Bercy pardon parce que ça
sort de mon champ de compétences il
travaille sur les modalités et l'acuité
des vérifications menées lors de la
création des comptes notamment pour
éviter la création de compte avec les
mêmes types d'identité l'utilisation de
photos identiques pour des comptes
différents parce que parfois et pour ne
pas dire souvent cela peut dissimuler
évidemment des situations irrégulières
et parfois des personnes en situation
irrégulière sur notre territoire et ce
que je dis là et vrai aussi sur
l'acuité donc du contrôle y compris sur
des pièces d'identités qui sont juste
mais des titres qui pourraient être
arriver à échéance donc pour éviter que
se crée des situations dans lesquelles
nous aurions des personnes nous avons
des personnes qui sont en situation
irrégulière sur notre territoire mais
qui du fait de leur enregistrement comme
auto-entrepreneur comme ils entrepreneur
exerce une activité qui elle est légale
et donc créer des grandes difficultés de
droit et d'appréciation de leur
situation les services du gouvernement
au sens large vont améliorer améliorer
les dispositifs de vérification des
identités de la validité des identités
de la validité de la validité des titres
merci Madame Chandler
monsieur le ministre vous avez indiqué
que des premiers accords ont été signés
par là pouvez-vous nous indiquer quels
sont les prochaines étapes prévues sur
le dialogue social
je ne reviens pas madame la députée sur
les accords qui ont été signés donc tant
dans le secteur des chauffeurs VTC que
des livraisons c'était de premiers
accords nous avons assisté mon collègue
ministre des Transports que vous allez
au-dessus dans un instant et moi-même à
la signature des premiers accords
concernant les chauffeurs et en avril
nous avons appris avec satisfaction on
va dire la possibilité que trois
nouveaux accords soient signés
aujourd'hui la priorité qui est qui
poursuivie par les différentes
organisations représentatives de
travailleurs plateformes et de
travailler sur les revenus les
conditions de travail et quand j'ai des
revenus c'est notamment le niveau du
revenu horaire sachant que dans le cadre
des ordonnances qui ont été prises et du
droit qui était fixé je l'ai indiqué
dans mon propos liminaire il y a quatre
thèmes qui doivent faire l'objet de
négociation annuelle puisque le droit
prévoit que les différents représentants
de plateformes comme de travers
plateforme doivent ouvrir des
négociations sur au moins un des quatre
thèmes prioritaires chaque année et donc
c'est dans ce cadre là que le dialogue
social va se poursuivre
et pardonnez-moi nous sommes attentifs
l'ARPE est attentive et c'est un point
qui est important dans un secteur où le
dialogue social est naissant aux
conditions d'exercice des fonctions de
représentants des travailleurs de
plateformes ça fait l'objet d'accord
dans les deux cas ni vraiment et
chauffeur VTC mais ça fait partie des
discussions qui sont encore en cours
certains représentants nous ayant dit
par exemple la signature des premiers
accords que c'était un premier pas mais
qui souhaitait que ça puisse aller plus
loin notamment sur le caractère
forfaitaire et le montant forfaitaire
d'indemnisation lorsqu'ils doivent
interrompre leur activité le temps du
dialogue social et des réunions
organisées par là
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué le fait que
votre de votre préférence de votre
souhait de soutenir plutôt la prévention
d'indépendance par rapport à la
présomption de salariat concernant la
projet directive européenne alors vous
tenez que il s'agit là de finalement
juridiquement de concept assez identique
ce que je ne crois pas avec Madame la
rapporteur mais en tout cas en tout état
de cause politiquement ça ne l'est pas
du tout et ne croyez-vous pas que le
rôle du ministre du Travail dans notre
pays en France lorsque vous défendez le
dialogue social ce n'est pas d'adopter
et de défendre des propositions qui sont
favorables aux salariat dans le sens où
il y a une subordination dans le sens où
il y a c'est petit auto-entrepreneurs
qui sont quand même face à des grands
des très grandes plateformes qui elles
ont beaucoup de pouvoir et donc
finalement il y aurait-il pas là une
disproportion telle de moyens mise à
disposition des présumés salariés ou des
présumés indépendants qui seraient quand
même logique normal quand on se réfère à
social-démocratie que l'État Vienne en
soutient des petits
sont des concepts qui ne sont pas tout à
fait identiques mais ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est que ce qui compte
notamment dans un système où le juge
peut procéder comme il le fait des
requalifications c'est la réalité des
conditions d'exercice c'est ça qui
détermine l'indépendance ou la
requalification en salariat ou quelqu'un
dépense ou la demande indépendance pour
ce qui concerne la responsabilité qu'il
a mienne elle avant toute permettre à
tous les travers de ce pays de
travailler avec le statut qu'il
choisisse à condition que ce statut
corresponde à la réalité de leurs
conditions d'exercice et le choix que
nous avons fait qui n'est pas un choix
que j'ai fait c'est un choix historique
de la France en la matière c'est de
confier au juge le soin de requalifier
lorsqu'il considère que les conditions
réelles d'exercices d'une activité ne
correspondent pas au statut qui est
affiché ou avancé par tel ou tel des
parties
nous sommes arrivés au terme de notre
audition monsieur le mini je vous
remercie pour votre disponibilité pour
la précision de vos réponses il y a des
demandes de document de la rapporteur il
nous reste quelques semaines encore dans
la commission d'enquête je vous
remercierai de nous les faire parvenir
mais dans l'intervalle je vous souhaite
une excellente journée et nous allons
passer à l'audition du ministre des
Transports merci beaucoup merci à vous